- I feel like Lex Luther when I do this.
This must be what he
does, his morning ritual.
Every day.
(upbeat music)
- I've gotten close.
I've buzzed down to like a one or a two
every once in a while, you
know, I tease it a little bit.
But no, I've never shaved
my head all the way.
- All of a sudden you wake up
and that widow's peak that I used to have
now kinda started going backwards.
- I didn't want to believe
that I was losing my hair.
So you kinda ignore it for a while.
- Started at the age of 20.
At 20 you're supposed to
have a full head of hair.
- Soon as it starts to happen to you,
you start to think about these things.
- You definitely go through
that self conscious stage
where you're trying to hide it.
- I am balding. I can't be balding.
I look older.
- People are gonna think
differently of me now
because of this.
- I might as well just bite the bullet
and see what I look like all the way bald.
People has said I probably
have a good head for it.
- Sometimes going bald can
look pretty sexy, so...
- I really hope that I will look good.
You know some people have the head for it,
other people do not, and you
don't necessarily find that out
until you've gone there.
- Yeah let's shave this head.
- Yeah let's try it.
- Shave it off.
(heavy metal music)
Here goes nothing.
(electric razor)
- I've never seen myself as a bald head.
- Getting rained on by my own hair.
- That was a big chunk of
hair that just fell off.
- I really don't know why
I've never done this before.
- Am I good?
- I think that now it's time to go full.
- Alright let's do this.
- The instruction manual said
that we have to have this.
- I'm just gonna go overboard.
- I'm really excited
to see how this looks.
- Alright, moment of truth here.
- We'll see about my girlfriend.
She might not like it as much.
- I'm kinda sold on this already.
I haven't seen it yet, but it feels dope.
- This is a weird feeling.
- My head is not used to being shaved.
- It's just my skin.
(upbeat folk music)
- Oh yeah that's definitely bald.
- Ohh shhhhh....
- I like it, wow.
(laughing)
- I guess it plays to the evilness.
Maybe, maybe.
- Definitely interesting
thing to get used to,
seeing yourself with no hair.
- I just saved a lot of money on haircuts.
- I can feel the breeze.
If there was a breeze in here.
- I think this is
something I could do again.
- I like the shape of my head fortunately.
- Whether or not I like it,
it's definitely easier than
trying to combat going bald.
- If I saw myself on the street,
I would think wow that guy
has a lot of confidence,
just to shave all his hair off like that.
And not care necessarily
what people think.
- I don't care if I am bald, long hair,
short hair, totally bald, half bald,
it doesn't matter to me because
I'm always true to myself.
And that's kind of why
I don't mind this look.
I like to think I'm true to myself.